joining me now is jim banks indiana
indiana congressman and newt gingrich
former speaker of the house and fox news
contributor congressman banks 19
senators basically signed on with the
left to
go right into the reconciliation bill we
knew this was going to happen senator
cassidy tried to debate me on this and
sorry he ended up looking like a fool
your response
well this is just insane laura we're
trying to win back majorities in the
house and the senate how do you do that
when republicans act like democrats how
do we convince the american people to
vote to give republicans the trust once
again to lead when they see stuff like
this happen today we know that inflation
is on the rise the price of everyday
goods costs more and real wages are
declining in america it's only going to
get worse because of this deal it's a
travesty
that republicans would go along with it
also laura you have to recognize that
the same republican senators that went
along with this infrastructure deal that
only nine percent of it is actually
infrastructure the same republican
senators that denied
donald trump an infrastructure deal that
cost half of this that all of it went to
infrastructure they wouldn't let him
accomplish that under donald trump's
watch why did they go along with
democrats and give give joe biden a win
on biden's watch i just don't get it
now nancy pelosi speaker of the house
she reacted to the passage of this uh
bill and it was instructive watch
with all the respect in the world for
the senate bill
i'm glad it passed i'm glad it's
bipartisan
but it is not
the totality of the vision of joe biden
and the congressional democrats
if we could have to do this much
bipartisan okay but that is not the
vision the vision is to build back
better
i love the hand emotions newt uh they're
rubbing republicans faces in this after
republicans were trying to assure
our viewers and conservatives across the
country that it would make it less
likely that the 3.5 trillion would
ultimately pass in some form your
reaction
well milk it's very hard to understand i
agree
with jim
i can't understand why a single
republican senator would have voted for
this
it didn't meet any of the standards they
promised it isn't paid for it isn't
restricted just to infrastructure it
does have tax increases in it it has all
sorts of
left-wing proposals and projects and
ideas
it massively pays off schumer in new
york city
with what i think is a uh
enormously expensive uh tunnel
that probably is larger than about half
the state's share of the infrastructure
part of this
and it has no really serious reforms in
it
i can't imagine how these republicans
can go home and with a straight face
suggest
that they voted for something that's
truly bipartisan and of course it's all
going to get worse in the house because
pelosi is running a dictatorship and she
has absolute control of her
narrow margins but it's
it's a sufficient margin so who knows
what's going to come back and i think uh
from the standpoint of any conservative
vote in america this is a disaster it's
an unnecessary disaster and it's a
self-inflicted wound by the senate
republicans yeah congressman bernie
sanders is calling the next monstrosity
which is the follow-on reconciliation
bill the most consequential bill since
the new deal
so to remind everyone universal
preschool two years of free community
college adding dental vision and hearing
benefits to medicare cutting carbon
emissions by 50 by 2030 and an
immigration overhaul
that ends up being amnesty it's just the
tip of the iceberg an enormous amount on
uh the new climate corps and climate
change giveaways congressman
could the house possibly stop this
i hope so we've we've been called back
the week after next laura the house will
come back into session we will do
everything we can to stop this what the
american people need to know is that joe
biden is a socialist
president he's governing as a socialist
he's adopted the bernie sanders playbook
and this is a big example of that but
also on top of that this will grant the
the widest reaching amnesty that this
country has ever seen to 12 to somewhere
between 12 and 20 million illegals
including a million and a half migrants
who have come into this country
illegally since joe biden has been
president this bill will do that too so
it's dangerous on many levels we'll do
everything we can to fight against it
and stop it all right a new poll on newt
is showing that americans optimism after
you know six months of biden has taken a
nosedive it's dropped nearly 20 percent
20 points excuse me since may
are you surprised that this agenda and
what we're seeing at the border
obviously new covet variants and so
forth that the democrats still decide to
go left when they marketed biden as a
moderate
no i look i think the democrats are
caught
in the logic
of bernie sanders and aoc and
the left wing of their party uh you know
the three and i think jim just captured
it perfectly this bill could be entitled
socialism now
uh because that's certainly why bernie
sanders is excited this bill could be
entitled
more inflation faster because that's
what larry summers the democratic former
sector of the treasury has been trying
to warn them about and this bill is a
further reminder that the biden
administration is committed to treating
illegal immigrants better than they
treat americans
and i think it's very significant that
the buy demonstration refuses to tell us
where they're sending people last month
they had 210 000 illegal immigrants we
know of which is about the city of
birmingham alabama we have no idea where
they were sent we have no idea how many
of them have covered we have no many
idea how many of them have criminal
records a friend of mine just told me
and we haven't been able to verify yet
that they're actually being flown into
hawaii
uh if that turns out to be true and
you're in a situation where you the
average viewer can't afford to go to
hawaii for a vacation but there are
seats being taken up on a plane by an
illegal immigrant it'll tell you just
how sick this administration is yeah
well there needs to be legal actions
filed to
for a demand
of this information the governors and
the states have a right to know what the
federal government is doing to try to
change their states forever
congressman and newt thank you for the
insights tonight as always hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else